I have a message for the refugees and I
would like to say welcome to Canada
but as artists what's great is when we
have people that take our music take
what we do and bring it to another level
and that only an audience can do I've
been dreaming about this for many years
and three years ago we had been doing
some Christian music some Hebrew music
music from Africa from Haiti from
Southern America and I said I have to
have something from the Muslim world
so we went to the local Muslim community
and asked them is this okay are we like
doing something wrong or is it okay to
do this in this particular context and
they said yes no problem do it
this song came in the right time we
would that message to be sent to the
world from you know a peaceful country
like Canada or respected country I think
the timing was great we needed that